a new event has arrived in Destiny's
world to celebrate the upcoming
Valentine's Day holiday crimson day will
bring you and another fellow Guardian
closer together as you get to experience
a brand new PvP mode together in this
new PvP mode power will not matter so
feel free to dust off some of those
oldie but goodies like The Thorn
icebreaker and more you and your fellow
Guardian will try to eliminate the other
team if your partner happens to fall you
will be heartbroken which will grant you
a temporary buff you'll be faster on the
draw reloading your weapon and recover
health much quicker just like trials of
Osiris the goal is to get the five wins
first there are new bounties at Lord
checks to get and when completing them
you have a chance to get new loot in
addition by playing crimson doubles
you'll have a chance and new shaders and
go shells that can hit up to 320 light
also tests at the eros station has new
emotes that you can purchase channel
your inner Drake and perform the strange
dance or maybe some of the courage to be
like Napoleon Dynamite and get your
groove on there's also the secret
handshake the fist bump and the charmed
emo unfortunately these will still cost
you silver and cannot be earned in the
game there are however two new free
emotes you can get at the emote station
near the bar so the question is will you
be joining up with another Guardian to
participate in this new event or has
destiny come and gone for you tell me in
the comments below and stay tuned to
gamespot com for more destiny coverage
starting down off Guardian stand
for enemies have beaten
you